all of us can play a powerful and
engaged part at this the most pivotal
moment in human history hi I miss I have
been working on climate change for
longer than you would care to know first
as a negotiator of the climate
convention from my home country Costa
Rica from which I am speaking today and
then undertaking several
responsibilities at the international
level including delivering the Paris
agreement in 2015 my name is Tom Murphy
carnac I was the head of political
strategy for the Paris agreement working
with Christiana and I've continued to
collaborate with her ever since we run a
podcast together called outrage and
optimism and we recently co-authored the
book the future we choose the book is
meant to be a helpful guide to what each
of us as individuals can do to
contribute to climate solutions yes of
course we need systemic policies on
financial investments that are also
going to help but as we have learned
from coronavirus we need both systemic
changes as well as individual behavior
changes we need both every one of us you
know what our carbon footprint is
usually we check our bank account at
least once a week to know how we're
doing on our bank account we should also
know how we're doing on our carbon
account if you don't know what your
carbon footprint is is pretty simple to
find out you go to Google you type in
carbon calculator and up comes a long
list of Carbon calculators that have
been put out by many reputable
institutions every one of us should know
what our starting line is some of us
will have a higher footprint than others
don't condemn yourself for having a high
footprint is just where we all start the
important thing is not where we start
the important thing is that we commit to
reducing that carbon fragment the
questions that will be asked of you will
also be very helpful because they will
already indicate to you where you can
reduce your carbon footprint climate
change used to be something that was
separated from us bite
I mean it was supposed to happen in the
future but we're already seeing
continents burning Australia has burned
with half a billion animals lost many
endemic species the Amazon has been on
fire California the Arctic these are
early signs and this is just going to
get worse if we don't get on top of it
getting on top of it means that we need
to be at Net Zero well before 2050 if we
are not then temperature rise will go
beyond 1.5 degrees and what will happen
is the climate of the planet will spin
out of control and we will lose the
ability to have any impact on this even
if we reduce emissions that's the
nightmare scenario that we need to avoid
so to get there we need to have
emissions 50% less than they are right
now by 2030 after that we need to be at
Net Zero as soon as possible ideally by
2040 but certainly by 2050 those are the
decades we have no-one else is going to
do this if this is going to be done it's
going to be successful or if it's going
to be a failure it's going to be us that
does it if we think about our footprint
in a 10-year time frame that's enough
time to do this right that ten year
period will probably encompass a whole
range of changes in the
capital-intensive items of your life
most emissions will come from a boiler
they'll come from a car or a furnace or
something like that and many of those
items will be replaced within a 10 year
time frame anyway so thinking about it
in that a slightly longer time frame
gives you a chance to kind of make
different decisions when those big
capital intensive investments come up
you can also be much more mindful about
our transport whether it's by land or by
air or maritime one thing that we have
learned now with this coronavirus
epidemic is that maybe we don't need to
transport ourselves as much as we think
is necessary maybe we actually do much
more telecommuting for a daily work or
even for meetings I mean who knew that
we would get a chance to see whether the
world can shift to telecommuting so
quickly but what's amazing is we've seen
an an unprecedented transition as a
result of the pandemic that people have
had to stay home they've had to make
telecommuting work much of our work can
carry on engaging remotely
so for the vast majority of us who would
live in Europe or North America our
footprint will mainly consist of two
things if we get on a plane it will be
that and what we eat the amount of
emissions that goes into producing meat
is huge so brief is the worst culprit
but pork and chicken and lamb are all
part of that too now we can all make a
difference if we aren't yet ready and
prepared to give up me or go plant-based
which is very good for your health and
you feel better on it which I can
personally attest to then you can just
stop eating it either one day a week or
two days a week or one meal a day try
and add more meals in your life that are
vegetarian but a plant-based it'll make
a difference to how you feel and it will
make a big difference for the planet you
can also look at the energy that you're
using are you wasting energy and all of
us I can I promise all of us waste
energy but we leave things on longer
than they need to who turn lights on in
one room and then we leave if we don't
turn it off so we can all be much more
energy efficient
so while none of us can leave our homes
one thing that's really worth doing is
trying to figure out where the emissions
from your home come from that's actually
pretty easy to do you can find all kinds
of websites that will give you direction
and there's a whole bunch of stuff that
you can do either yourself or by
engaging with those companies that
provide you with services to reduce your
emissions I mean one basic thing you can
do is if you live in a home that has
drafts you can go around even right now
and close off those drafts it can make a
massive difference to your energy bills
the other thing you can do is actually
talk to your suppliers and find out if
they can provide you with a renewable
energy tariff if they can't there are
certainly others in the competitive
landscape who can do that and
increasingly you don't even have to pay
anymore you can also be much more
mindful of which companies are you
actually buying goods and services from
there are companies that are being much
more responsible on climate and others
that are being much more irresponsible
the forests and the strength of
consumers and clients is very strong
hopefully you are voting with your
wallet we have unfortunately grown up in
cultures that are based on irresponsible
consumerism and assuming more than we
need is not
helpful to us and certainly not helpful
to the planet so we have to learn when
enough is enough right now we can't
leave our homes but there's a huge
amount that we can do so I would
encourage everybody who's at home to
participate in digital strikes which are
already and still going on and also to
use this moment to find out who your
elected representative is and make your
voice heard we all have a few minutes
now now that we're home that will make
more of a difference than you riddle
most elected representatives never hear
from their constituents about climate
change let's change that well we're all
under lockdown don't be afraid to engage
in politics don't be afraid to engage
it's very important to plant the flag of
where we know we have to go and what we
want for our future one of the mindset
that we talk about in the book is
stubborn optimism and what we mean by
that is that while it is absolutely
understandable that we are all in deep
grief about the losses that we are
seeing and while it is very
understandable that we get angry about
the fact that the decisions are not
being made quickly enough it is also
very important to not allow that anger
and that grief to drop us into a hole of
hopelessness and helplessness because if
we allow ourselves to drop into that
hole we are not being helpful to the
transition that we have to make so our
suggestion is certainly to honor that
grief to honor that anger which we also
partake in but at the same time be
courageous enough out of the anger and
out of the grief to play your part so I
invite all of you to become members of a
growing family of stubborn optimists
around the world
[Music]